but like I always hear horror stories
about Faye Dunaway and I just want to
know if any of it's true or did you ever
see that or let's just say was she just
Intense or something you could remember
or maybe everything was great you know I
did not have many scenes with her so for
me
um what I the thing I remember was
now that I'm gonna be 60 years old this
year wow you look great and so she was
probably thank you she was probably only
45 maybe I don't know we can look it up
but how concerned she was with the
lighting and the perfectionism of an
aging woman and being really struck by
that more than anything else more than
is she difficult or that was the thing
like really tampering with the lights
making sure it was
um you know being self-protective being
I never have had that like I've been on
TV shows forever and there are actresses
they just are making I it's sort of like
I hope
so what you guys have in other words
you're saying
they take care of themselves the DP
trust me but in a way I've seen things
I've been in my one of my closest
friends Helen Hunt we have a very funny
story one of your closest friends she
introduced me to my husband what yeah I
love that one do you know what I always
think about when I think of Helen Hunt
her amazing moment in Castaway when she
hears that he's alive and she collapses
in the kitchen oh that just dropped me
that's such an incredible anyway I love
her go ahead I was doing a series in
Austin and we're hiking when I got back
and I was like I I look so awful like I
said I was like oh hell Bill I just look
so terrible does that mean I saw the
thing I just can't believe out and she
go and I'm like why do I look so awful
she said because we're dying
and I was like well if we're dying I
guess I look pretty fantastic and it
really popped it for me from that moment
on I was like yeah we're aging I'm dying
it looks like that I'm I'm done oh my
God right that is exceptional advice
right think about it but that makes a
lot of sense you talk about like getting
older and we all do like I I even look
to some degree
um you know I don't look at him and say
hey how's I just kind of just let
everything go and then it is what it is
yeah but I definitely look at myself
sometimes and I'm just like wow
wow you just you're just not the kid you
sometimes feel like or you remember and
you're looking more and more like an
older person and this is just the way it
goes this is again this is this is life
it can't be can't stop Yes
um but you know I but I could sort of
understand too it's much harder for a
woman it's much harder your whole life
when you especially when you're an actor
it's not especially you're an actress
but when you're an actress it's like
you know
um look there's a premium on how you
look there's a premium on pretty there's
a premium on you know they're just we
just value that so much in our culture
and we don't have as many avenues for
be Elder women or aging or you know but
there are
there's all right I go through this like
I'm like I see all these guys my age and
they're all ripped
a lot of them doing probably you know
testosterone HGH which is fine do
whatever you want to do I don't give a
[__] you know I might even start it but
uh the point is I look at them and I'm
like oh my gosh
man do I need to look like that I'm like
why do you need to look like that are
you doing a superhero movie yeah what do
you need to do I don't want to work out
that much I don't want to hurt my body
I've already had surgeries I don't feel
like doing anything you know what I mean
so I don't want to do this [__] I'll
play some sports I'll have some fun I'll
try to be as healthy as I can but like I
don't want to like constantly just be
ripped and shredded and drinking these
beans and leaves and and it just it's so
daunting and it's so it's so hard to do
that and the overall
um result could be fascinating and
you're but then you have to maintain it
yeah it's like the part of me is like
shouldn't the 50 year old kind of look
like a 50 year old like they used to
when you used to watch movies like
George C Scott's 58 he looks like he's
80. what the [__] happened to him it's
true we've had a weird you know
difference so everybody's trying to be
looking as young as they can and well
cigarettes and alcohol will do that
that's true that's true